the envelopes please mr. Hofer where we
hear the sound of the envelope tearing
please
you open it doors all right the winner
is and the winner is and the Oscar goes
to the Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes
to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you mean there's no help
gee I never noticed that put a wig on it
each day teeth would go in contact
lenses and the wigs would find the beef
budget tons of times a hair and upper
left and nostrils it's more than just
the ears the eyebrows are just
unimportant a little difference is you
have to do the coloring and matching and
the age spots imagining every day
it's insane you have to do the entire
face faces bodies and hands are
transformed through the use of molds
prosthetics wigs appliances and most of
all a creative eye and a vivid
imagination
[Music]
they are really
hero an art that goes back to the
ancient Egyptians and which our makeup
office continued to improve
[Music]
the winner is America
[Music]
the Oscar for makeup goes to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well hello and welcome to the Oscar week
makeup artist and hairstylist symposium
yeah we're here my name is Lois Burwell
and I'm chairman and one of the three
makeup and hairstyling branch governors
hosting this program you'll be hearing
from vice-chair leonard Engelmann and
hair stylist governor kathy blundell
shortly the Academy gives the the Oscar
to honor and celebrate the art of motion
pictures we are here today to celebrate
some exceptional work in the art of
makeup and hairstyling in a motion
picture each one of our nominees are
winners already only one will take home
the Oscar but each one has proven their
work to be exceptional by the fact that
they are here today in today's program
we will introduce each film what work is
being considered for that film then we
will invite the artist for that film to
the stage to discuss and show some
photographs to explore in greater detail
methods materials and how it all came
together to create their wonderful work
we will then screen the 10-minute reel
shown at the bake-off I know that's a
mystifying expression but it will be
explained shortly it has nothing to do
with fairy cakes once we have seen and
spoken with all three film artists we
will then invite all the nominees to the
stage for a Q&A from you the audience
our three films nominees this year are
for the darkest hour Kara here is suji
David Malinowski and Lucie Civic for
Victoria and Abdul Daniel Phillips a new
Shepherd for Wonder re-indict in' what
before we begin please would all the
nominees stand and face the audience so
he can actually give you thanks for the
work you've done on the silver screen
[Applause]
over to you limit today is a celebration
of winners every nominee that steps on
this stage today as a winner and every
now and eat tomorrow and in the past as
a winner the Oscar tells us that the
world that filmmaking is an art and it's
being practiced by some people at a very
high level some of those people are in
the room today they are past Oscar
recipients and nominees when I call your
name please stand and remain standing
until the end Christina Smith Martin
Samuel
Robert can Dini Robert short Richard
Alonzo bill Corso Michelle Burt Kevin
haini eidi French Barbara Lorenz Deborah
Lamia denavir dance tree Peck Lois
Burwell Kazuhiro sushi
Michael is Aldi and Trevor Crower
fabulous work
[Applause]
we would also like to recognize from the
makeup artist and hairstylist Gil local
7:06 Tommy Cole business representative
suka Burrell Ebert sue Carell Ebert is
the president and assistant to the
business representative and Randy Sayer
who's the assistant to the business
representative and at this time we would
also like to thank the Academy's Randy
Hebert camp rose with Wilson and the
team for all the work and coordination
in making this function take place I've
told this story before but I feel that
it's very important in 1968 prior there
being a yearly Oscar for makeup Planet
of the Apes was going to receive a
special Academy Award that award as was
the process of the times would have gone
to the makeup department head at 20th
Century Fox Dentistry Peck Dan said the
person was responsible for this
achievement as John Chambers and he must
receive the Oscar it is that standard of
honesty and responsibility that we
follow today as the committee
painstakingly chooses the individuals
most responsible for what has been
recognized in each film today we have
dan street back in the audience dan
please stand
[Applause]
the selection of the film's is complex
it may be for the film in its entirety
for a makeup and hairstyling or for
makeup only or for hairstyling only or
for a specific character or characters
for makeup or makeup and hairstyling
from this we recognize the artists or
artists most responsible for those
achievements now please welcome
Catherine Blondell our branch is well
aware of how our nominees nominations
are run but please allow me to inform
our guests and those who might not know
our procedure in April and October the
makeup artist and hair stylist Executive
Committee meet as part of the business
they discussed the list of films that
have been released during the year
during the previous month's out of these
films come recommendations of films to
be seen for makeup and and/or
hairstyling the list of films that have
been discussed is posted on our Academy
website throughout the year we would
like everyone to have the opportunity to
see these films as they come out on the
big screen so there are not so many to
be seen possibly only on DVD at the end
of the year we also encourage anyone
from our branch that has seen a movie
they feel should be seen to post that
film on our Academy discussion board so
we are able to go see that film in
November all branch members are asked to
attend a branch meeting to discuss the
film's and then in December and all
branch meeting is called to vote for the
seven films that will go on for
consideration
this year those seven films were Cho the
seven chil sorry the seven films that
were chosen were bright the darkest hour
ghost in the shell'
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 i tonyia
Victorian Abdul wonder following the BAP
December meeting the makeup art makeup
and hair stylist Executive Committee
meets and this meaning is to choose a
maximum of two names possibly three for
those most responsible for the look of
each film or character or characters
this decision is based on input and the
work that was done then in January all
members were asked to attend a
presentation by the makeup artists and
hairstylists recognized for the seven
films this is referred to as the
bake-off which was la watch was
live-streamed so our members who were
either on location or in other countries
could participate and vote then they
vote online Academy makeup artists and
hairstylists members spend a tremendous
amount of unselfish time in an effort to
applaud the work of others we also have
to thank our staff members at the
academy Tom Meyer and Michelle Iola for
that spend numerous hours above and
beyond the working week to help us get
all of our work done now let's meet our
nominees the first film we're going to
see and discuss is the darkest hour
please welcome to the stage Casso hero
sushi
Kazu is credited as the prosthetic
makeup and hair designer for gary oldman
this is the third Oscar nomination for
kazoo he was nominated for click and for
Norbit two weeks ago cause he received a
BAFTA award and one week ago a makeup
artist artist and hairstylist Guild
Award for darkest hour President Lee
Kazu is designing projects please
welcome David Malinowski to the stage
[Applause]
David is credited as the personal makeup
artist for gary oldman and prosthetic
makeup supervisor for gary oldman two
weeks ago David received a BAFTA award
and one week ago a makeup artist and
hairstylist Guild Award or the darkest
hour
[Applause]
David recently completed Bohemian
Rhapsody and welcome Lucy Civic Lucy is
credited as a prosthetic makeup and hair
artist for Gary Coleman now two weeks
ago Lucy received a BAFTA award and one
week ago a makeup artist and hairstylist
Guild Award for Tarkus tower and Lucy is
presently working on Game of Thrones
[Laughter]
well that almost got the biggest
applause of all let's take a look at our
first photo here see the photos on the
the screen up here to me this is so
amazing because you don't see Gary in
the makeup and one of the things that I
thought was so fantastic darkest hour
won a lot of awards Gary won a lot of
awards and every time he won award he
would thank his team he thanked his team
and he named every one of them now as
you know that doesn't happen very often
okay but it was wonderful that he
considered his team and to me knowing
sort of what took place I think there
were four people in the team I think the
three here and I think Gary was also
part of that team tell us Kazu or David
actually tell us a little bit about what
was happening during the process of
filming because I think it's unusual
that he was so participating yeah you
know Gary's amazing amazing actor
amazing friend and he's just amazing in
the chair
he would he would come in at ridiculous
times the morning I don't know the
earliest time he was in probably three
or four with more animals and it to
apply his makeup and which shave his
head every day which is really
frustrating just the sound of the razor
buzzing in his ear but he would just sit
there if we wanted him to close his eyes
open his eyes sit still maybe said he
would just do exactly what we said when
we wanted it because he realized that
that's our time to work
you know that's he respects our craft we
do our job and if he does what we want
he gets the best result you know the
best makeup result is achieved and then
when he goes to set he does a similar
thing you know he wants the respect back
he wants people to be quiet when he's
acting he doesn't want you to be messing
around in the background so yeah he's
amazing we've been really spoiled with
Gary yeah definitely the best actor I've
worked on so far I think that's worth
the round of applause
[Applause]
and Lucy also while everybody was on the
set I believe that he was very
respectful and took care of the makeup
is that correct yes he was really good
and we didn't have huge amount of time
for checks so he was really patient and
would always let me you know touch up
the wig or do any little highlighter you
know say there anything that we needed
to do so then when I when it was checks
we you know could focus on the important
things
the as we look at these two images it's
almost hard to believe that the image on
the right is it's Gary Oldman you just
don't see Gary Oldman especially if
you've seen the film in the film from
moment one you don't see Gary Oldman
let's take a look at the next slide now
here we see one of the one of the
prosthetic that's being applied and also
the mold that this came from and Kazu
I believe this must have been one of the
test makeups because I see that there's
a ball cap and I know that he shaved his
head later but just tell us a little bit
what
how many appliances were involved in
this and how did this come about so we
did three different tests at first and
kind of varies from light medium heavy
and we were trying different look and to
figure out what would be the best way to
go because it's Gary doesn't look like
charger at all so we have to figure out
what would be the best balance to do as
a makeup and what we set out on was so
he has a nose tip and chin and a pair of
cheeks and a big neck piece and I also
put a vacuum foam behind his ear too
after his ear shape and he also had the
bodysuit
and we had a wig on so we had some
pieces on his forehead like because the
charger has a big scar on the middle of
the forehead but we've thought it's not
important for the movie the content of
the movie because there's no explanation
how he got the scar on the forehead and
because it will create more problem on
cells rather than explain something so
that's how we became like a wise choice
how many knew that Churchill had a scar
on his forehead two three okay okay I
hope you're telling the truth okay so
there it was a certainly a wise decision
to make that change so did you started
off and with quite a number of
appliances then by the time you got done
to actually the filming mm-hmm
then were there fewer appliances other
than the forehead yes because yeah we
had I think it's a we had some other
like eyelids and other pieces but yeah
we set on on that those piece and that
the sculpture on right is that the last
piece i sculpted actually in spain
another kind of last-minute change
because i thought i could improve the
look more even more to look like a
charger and i sculpted the oval over the
weekend and this molded it and both back
and that worked out great so yeah there
is nothing like perfection this was
certainly a great undertaking and you
know we can see part of that let's take
a look at the next clip here now or the
next photo okay now here we see the wig
and gary in the process and i have to
say that I thought the wig and the whole
look of the wig was just so amazing and
Casso i believe that you made the wig
you tell us a little about the wig and
the hair and the lace yeah and here's
Diana Choi and she's a my wig maker and
she made a wig
so we used English students for the
front and we mixed baby European here
with Angola here and we tried to make it
as fine as possible because we tend to
look too heavy I didn't want that look
so I wanted to make it natural and they
also the skin underneath show through so
we did and it was quite tricky wig to
apply to because if if there's any kind
of imperfection it will show through and
but Lucy maintained their own five weeks
onset and she did an amazing job I think
so you had five wigs and I believe
because they were somewhat fragile yeah
that's why you need so many this only
lasts for probably ten days of shooting
so we have to be placed to the new wigs
and you know I a few months ago when we
had the some of the photos that you're
going to see downstairs our executive
committee was looking at these photos
and just amazed because we saw no edges
and appliance as we know saw no anything
we just saw skin we were looking at the
at the wigs and you know the application
and several of us said well you know
it's not a wig now they they punched the
hair they very definitely they punched
the hair and we were all wrong it was a
wig and it was just beautifully applied
and beautifully dressed so many times a
wig ends up to be just sort of straight
hair but in this case it had swirls it
had movement you know it became real and
Lucy so many times the wig in the back
just sort of sticks out straight but you
had a way of taking care of it that I
thought was so unique I'd never heard of
it before
you explain what you did there
well the first few days we went to SAP
we find in the back of the wig would
kick up from where the appliance was and
where the collar was so myself and David
thought we're gonna have to find a way
to nail this down because otherwise
we're gonna be in hell for the whole
film so we decided we'd sew it to the
appliance so that's what we did we just
did like a thread all the way through
and not kind of solved the problem and I
think Gary was pleased about that
actually because the first few days we
did go in and Pastor him a bit okay
let's take a look at the at the other
next photos here okay here you see
pretty well completed probably touching
up on the set and some wonderful work
and David in David and Lucy in applying
the pieces how did you go about that
when what was the first piece and then
the next piece so we would put the neck
on first over the head and we had a foam
piece that went underneath the neck to
bridge the gap between the bodysuit and
the appliance and then we did a cheek
first so I don't come my side David help
there and then he'd go back to his cheek
and then we I paint the head and then
we'd go on with the nose tip and then
the chin we try and save that to last
because that was probably one of the
most tricky ones today I think well it
worked out great now you obviously had a
very large team because you had to
prepare you the appliances were made
elsewhere you had to prepare them pre
color them apply and maintain during the
day you had to prepare for the next day
you had to remove the makeup which I
believe was about an hour and then you
had to try to get some sleep now how
many people were on your team just has
to say is that great yeah we did the
whole thing
[Applause]
okay let's take a look at our next slide
here or and here you see Winston
Churchill standing with the bodysuit on
you know the whole character and
everything and I know the story from the
very beginning when they first talked to
Gary about taking on this character and
if I'm correct he said well the only way
I'll do it is if Kazu doesn't correct
fantastic okay
all right we're going to take a look now
at our film clip and congratulations and
all the best tomorrow
[Applause]
the German army invaded Holland and
burned from early this morning by then
there's a telegram on damnation from
paratroops the armies of countries
it's from the palace thank you miss
Layton hardly seems like there's a war
on at all
you know I've never ridden a bus so I've
never killed for Paige I believe I can
boil an egg but only because I've seen
it done and that was quite easy yes it
was I believe we are to meet regularly
once we can afraid how is how I'm for
Mondays
shrilling gave it to be available on
Mondays four o'clock I netted four is
that permissible no but necessary I give
you your father my beloved husband the
Prime Minister the Prime Minister
here's true so not buggering it up here
cover for our troops
the Luftwaffe control the skies we
simply don't have enough planes to
challenge it in fact I strongly
recommend we stop sending our precious
fighter planes to be wasted in France
save them for our own defense na Navy
sits idle neutralized useless
collectively we are looking at the
collapse of Western Europe in the next
few days should the public be told
no yet first swing Strauss our old
friends to have wrote resistance
[Music]
[Music]
Winston we're facing certain defeat on
land the annihilation of our army and
imminent invasion we must be rational we
are a seagoing nation there have been
since the Bronze Age the channel is ours
it's our MUX our Battlement and the
German doesn't recognize an expense of
water greater than a bloody Lake they
have first to reach this island Edward
we're men women and children whom we
will have failed despicably in our duty
of protection will be entirely defense
faulty snare against the largest army
the world has ever seen
furthermore once France Falls Germany
can concentrate on aircraft production
they will then have the French fleet as
well what is to stop here Hitler then
Winston words words words alone
I need not impressive on you yes a
trouble faced by the Western Hemisphere
without your support and some fishing
[Music]
nothing motorised and you could pull
them over the border yourself how does
that sound
offices and you did say a team of horses
I should like to discuss I have been
asked if plans should be drawn to
evacuate myself in my family to Canada I
would like to know the opinion of our
prime minister my opinion will be that
you must do what you feel is right for
yourself for your family and the nation
even your survival is paramount the
Prime Minister's
know we seem to come and go at an
astonishing rate Hitler will not insist
on outrageous terms he will know his own
weaknesses he will be reading my mother
lesson be learned
when brother know something learn by we
more dictators must be woo appeased of
god-given emits privileges
before we learn you cannot reason with a
tiger when your head is in its mouth
Belgium has fallen they will surrender
at midnight transfers in policy
do you know how to use this thing yes
sir how do I get to Westminster
Westminster I'm the district 9 East one
stop this videos each one stop that
doesn't sound so hard like that thank
you thank you sir
we shall not flag or fail we shall go on
to the air
we shall fight in France we shall fight
on the Seas and oceans we shall fight
with with growing confidence and go
extinct in year we shall defend our
island whatever the cost may be we shall
fight on the beaches we shall fight on
the landing grounds we shall fight in
the fields and in the streets we shall
fight in the Hills we shall never
surrender Danube which III do not for a
moment believe this island or large part
of it where where were subjugated and
starving then our Empire
we own the sieve ah and guarded by the
British fleet
but carry on the struggle until in God's
good time the new world we all need
Stowell and night skips forth to the
rescue and the liberation of the old
[Applause]
Victoria and Abdul Abdul Kareem arrives
from Indian to participate in Queen
Victoria's Golden Jubilee the young
clerk is surprised to find favor with
the Queen herself as Victoria questions
the constrictions of her long-held
position the to forge an unlikely and
devoted alliance that her household an
inner circle tried to destroy as the
friendship deepens the Queen begins to
see changing world through new eyes
joyfully reclaiming her humanity Daniel
Philips makeup and hair designer daniel
has been nominated and won many awards
including the BAFTA Luo Shepard Coe hair
designer Liu has also been nominated
several times for her well her work
please welcome Daniel Phillips and Liu
Shepard
[Applause]
congratulations well first of all I'd
like to ask you how the two of you
became involved in this project and what
were the objectives in designing the
look for this royal family I've received
praise for many years I think the first
film I ever did with him was the Queen
ten years ago or so
and I've known her for some time Lou I
used to be at the BBC who came to teach
his period hairdressing so that's how
Lou and I know each other
and then I haven't worked with Steven he
then invited me to work on this
production and it he made clear to me
that it wasn't a film about look-alikes
the audience knew Judy as Victoria in a
previous film it was really a film about
relationships and that my brief was to
portray the pain in her life at the time
before Abdul came onto the scene and
really just show that progression in her
life and that from the apathy in the
pain to the joy of meeting a new friend
that she could trust so that's how that
was my brief really it wasn't about
making a look-alike it was about more
about showing a relationship blossoming
I guess great are you both still hands
on with the makeup and hair and is that
important to you yes we're both hands on
I know sometimes people run in the
department just oversee it but we don't
believe in doing that we're really
hands-on all the time like we do all of
the fittings I generally make up the
lead actors I think probably most of us
is makeup artist we're all slow
control freaks and I think I know I
would I would certainly try and make
everybody up if I possibly could but up
you do have to let go somewhere but it's
important that I retain my skills and I
find more and more what's happening the
more the jobs I take on the bigger jobs
particularly I tend to be spending more
time pushing paper and doing budgets and
things so I always try to make up at
least one person just to keep my handing
because one has to remember that's why
I'm doing the job I do and it's so easy
to get bogged down and also you know I
love teaching I like having new students
so it's quite important that I keep my
skills up as well because obviously
we've got lots of great hair and makeup
artists but they're my they obviously
didn't all do this period that some have
never done it before
so we had a little workshops and went
through things and it's just a process
and then we got to where we did so we
had lots of prep on the job we had to we
we had lots of wigs that had to be
dressed separate pieces so it was really
quite quite a job and we had quite a big
team doing it great when you see lots of
prep a couple of weeks no I mean what I
mean isn't not we didn't have lots of
trip you didn't have like as we were
working we had to do in between lots of
I mean I'm lucky if I see an actor once
I think I saw Judy Icke because I've
worked with GT before so I know her but
we're lucky if we see an actor once for
a fitting I think I do and then you
probably had a week's prep and then you
and then you do your test you're lucky
if you get an actor for a makeup test
for a start and then you tend to just do
them on the day which is how we you know
wasn't a huge budget and you just get
everybody ready on the day and you hope
that you have everything available for
any unforeseen problems basically but
off the fun of it I have to say sorry
Kathy yeah I mean we kind of work out of
our kids quite a lot very much on set
makeup people and in-between things in
between setups and whatever we obviously
prep in doing bits
pieces trying to catch up I believe you
brought a guest with you today
mm-hmm all the way from California
[Applause]
just say nice things well you'll see
that their first photo that we have is
Ali's characters Abdul and would you
explain his look and the process that
you did to age him this is really only
an aging of about 10 years I think it
was in the story and it was something we
did enough little boss in Agra in India
we didn't really get the test makeup on
this and I think I remember people
knocking on the door for a saying we'd
only had like 30 minutes then are you
done yet are you done yeah we hadn't
really had many a practice the door
thing we had one practice in London and
we were having sooo because we're
shooting out a sequence all the time we
were just having to lay in hair that was
just um stipple latex if I remember and
some lenses you had some aging lens yeah
we had the lens so what we were freaking
out about the lenses first because the
lenses but had the lenses made and they
were just they were very very five
beautiful lenses with just a ring around
which just aged the eyes very slightly
and we open the box on the day and all
the colour had faded as she was the day
before the colour the flesh faded so we
managed to get them fed that FedEx out
again but that's upsetting for you but
that was those a lot of improvising yeah
I mean and also laying in bed especially
laying in a beard and you're trying to
do it in a certain amount of time
it's it's a it's a tricky business but
everybody it's up there on the big
screen basically but I think we kind of
got away with it
Ali can you tell us a little about your
experience with these two artists well
we'd be caged every morning in the truck
and that's it there would be we'd make
some magic I mean that's what was
happening for me was it was a wonderful
experience because all of us would come
together and I'd see every chair would
be you know this Judy being made up here
and there's you know Tim Pinkett Smith
as you know Eddie Izzard every
and it was it was phenomenal because
every look was different especially
Eddie's look you know you couldn't make
out it's Eddie and he's playing birdy
and he's totally transformed and this
was of course a lot of improvising that
happened in Agra because I remembered
you know we were just trying to figure
out where how many years is gonna be
ahead we wanted to it's a character that
existed in the 1800s and you had to fuse
him with modern times as well I mean
it's not that it's based in modern times
but there had to be that connect there's
no videos no photographs is hardly
anything so this whole look was I mean
there were endless meetings I remember
you know and it was one of those times
you never get to do makeup test and at
the back of your mind the date is
drawing near and Nora near and you're
thinking and now we're gonna get away
and it is literally I mean Steve and
bless him is lovely but he's not doesn't
leave a lot of time clearly it's very
tactful there so everything's a trust
job as it often is in in the films
really you never get the time that you
want but then they often that's what
that's how you do your best work in a
way you just improvise quickly and
that's the fun of it for us okay also I
look the arrival to London on the ship
was quite amazing and I'm sure that was
quite a lot of work Ali when from an
actor's point of view after makeup and
hair and they've created this whole
image for you to get off of the boat how
does that does that help you oh yeah I
mean of course it yeah it transforms you
it takes you takes you back there and
it's such a beautiful culmination of
costumes and makeup and of course the
setting itself there's also a lot you
don't actually see there is I mean what
I've seen Slough does a lot of our crowd
scene and organizes all of theirs and
there's a lot you don't that goes on
behind
you don't actually see which is often
the case yeah but um it was quite a busy
tell you that day if I you had a lot of
love makeup to be done there under the
crowds yeah well that was a very busy
scene I mean and it was photographed
from far away so you did see a lot of
the work okay the banquet hall I love
this it's beautiful makeup and hair from
royalty to the help and blue how was how
large was your team no I did I can't
recall how many essays we had extras we
had a big team yeah how to finds really
yeah we had to find really good people
obviously we do also have to have little
teachings as well we had to still do
that because as I said have a good they
are majority have never done this before
so we had to do all that yeah this was
my first day I remember that was we
would hit the ground running on this I
think we hit the ground running we were
in Scotland which was the yeah that was
a rough days show was a rough time then
straight back into this sorry I was
itchy I just remember there standing in
the clothes cuz I couldn't sit in a
console on I wouldn't let me sit because
you'd get the Creason and I had these
heavy costumes so yeah makeup was fine
[Laughter]
okay the Queen let's talk about the
Queen the Queen Judi Dench and all is
here she's seen in all of her looks
the look on the sorry Kathy the look on
the far right camera right you know is
that was the makeup test we did actually
which we did it blasted shields I think
it is that beautiful house they would do
move during a test them so it's really
seeing how severe we could make her look
that was really the only day we we had a
small test in London with what one test
for an hour and they all wanted to go
for lunch and you know what for test
days are like everything we over
glamorized everything and then we had to
start pulling it all back if I recall
because there had to be a transition of
Judy's look you know from off from quite
severe to suddenly blossoming and I
think if I recall that's the first
makeup test
yes that's blossom I called that blossom
that's when she softens that's when your
friendship develops isn't it early yeah
and these these are these makeups are
really you know there's nothing I'm not
going to say her and sale they're
fantastic products used they're
basically crying in grease paint makeups
and a little bit of skin illustrator
here and there but it's all done quite
quickly in a way that was most of the
film you know I remember the the
wheelchair shop there I'm in a corridor
being told to get out of the way by
Stephen Frears move move moving
it's done in about five minutes really
tends to but you know what I what I
loved about this entire process was that
it was the makeup and the costumes that
tell the time frame of this entire movie
because we don't we never had supers and
this this pans over 14 years 13 to 14
years this entire relationship that
these guys had
so those were the little subtleties that
were really important to me because I
would always go to Daniel you know or on
both of them in fact to just keep a
track of the timelines instead of my
script because there was nothing there
Lee Hall written the script that was in
a bubble sort of a love story like a
fantasy thing going there so it's the
costumes and the makeup that would just
take us through all the major events in
their lives I thought that was and then
we had several period women also
beautiful hair yes someone had weeks and
what about them wrong okay yes there was
pieces there and weeks obviously they
all had to have tests we had to dress
them all and you saw some of them today
yeah I did and yeah it's just everyday
thing for us really all done very
quickly not much time all done all the
fridges were set on little little
darlings we try and incorporate yeah
some of their own hair yes that was
Phipps on yeah all right that's partly I
don't have but but we do we do the
coloring in the cutting and make the
pieces wherever we can we meet yes they
were made this is yeah and also you know
day-to-day things like plastic partings
all the times but there is a skill in
which I find I get it when we get a lot
of students right I try to take on you
students on each job I'm doing new
people but they kind of underestimate
the importance of wig work you know
which is why it's so good for us to be
here on this stage and in this
competition competition in this
consideration because it's a kind of
dying art I feel this whole period
hairstyling thing it really is a drying
art and there's a lot of students that I
get that are not spending the time to
learn this skill and I learned from
and I learnt from college and I was a
hair stylist to start with but um people
underestimate how important good hair
styling good weed dressing is really I
mean it can kill a makeup you could do
the most beautiful makeup but if you've
got a bad wig you'll notice it straight
away if someone's a good hair stylist
they can make a bad wig look good
currently so that's why everybody should
learn their basic skills and they don't
seem to want to do it nowadays
you know they just think right we're
going to wing it and just go straight
and do the difficult stuff but you can't
so that's where all the basic skills
come into this job because we use them
all and we try to sort of as much as
possible do it in the way they did it so
great
Laurie up are they and let's look at the
men it was a beard fest
there's me again in another Georgie cap
I think that's right
lots of beards yeah of course the
problem one has now with the cameras def
high definition is is the lace a lot at
the time so we did a lot of beard laying
on hair laying on you you lucky you had
your own beard apart from at the end
obviously but even at the beginning
there's something about men in beards it
creates a lot of discussion in most
movies i producers don't like to see
their actors in beards if i recall on
most movies I've worked on there's
always some kind of issue with facial
hair but you can't get away with it on
this period production but we did a lot
of laying on their perches back to the
old you know Marcel tongs and and and
heaters and laying on of hair basically
and it's surprising how quickly you can
do this you know you can lay the tall
with the lace prelate may species is
they don't really hold under scrutiny
they don't hold for a long time they
don't last and I find by laying on full
beards or partial beards they'll last
the day really they don't budge it's
wonderful work it's really beautiful and
then you went on locations
hmm and you had to shoot outside oh my
god
go and I think everyone that's a makeup
and hair artist in this group will
understand oh my god I think someone
who's been there will understand doing
this there it's the mid Jesus you
remember the men they're like flying
piranhas yeah I mean I'm I'm sorry they
because we were told they're all they
look like mosquitoes and this simple
small thing I said I come from India you
know I've seen mine no mosquitoes these
things were new they were oh my god it
was yeah I remember the scene with Judy
and me and was sitting in the in the
boat and we we couldn't finish that
scene because suddenly Judy's about to
take her line and she goes you know and
I go and then I'm gonna know it Judy
wait we had a rapid you know I I hope
some of those bites got covered up in it
was a wonderful picture I do want to say
I think makeup in here for a period
movie is underestimated
I completely agree I hear so many
comments and this isn't a gripe it's
just really an observation actually
somebody said it to us at the hotel when
we were here for the nominees lunch this
at all they'll picture a nap - it wasn't
much hair makeup in that why are you up
for and we looked at each other didn't
we
but people don't appreciate they don't
know how much goes into something like
this and the beauty of is that you can't
see it and that's if you can't see it
then we've done our job well yes I agree
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chardee
office movement I wanted to speak to you
about the carpets we sent to the British
exhibition there is problems no no the
carpets went down very well in fact the
Governor General has received a letter
from the royal household thanking him
personally has all been such a success
he has decided to present the Queen with
a moher as part of the Jubilee of
Morrison mother only some sort of
ceremonial coin I have been asked to
find someone tall to present it you're
the tallest person here when will she be
arriving sir
not in agra in england you will travel
to England and present them over as an
official function like an equerry one of
ours
I didn't think I'll be a horse equity
always as always mr. daylor sir
well maybe not like an equity exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
eleven o'clock meeting with the Swedish
ambassador twelve o'clock luncheon with
Oscar the second king of Sweden in
Norway the Norwegian ambassador in chief
Undersecretary of State for the southern
Norwegian focuses the junior
Undersecretary of State for the northern
Norwegian provinces two o'clock
ceremonial drive down the mouth half
past two tea party at Hyde Park for
30,000 children
[Music]
she's here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
so your majesty
[Music]
there's another famine in India or
trouble in Ireland I'm afraid serious is
a perennial nightmare and I'm afraid the
Boers
their attitude is there any good news
Prime Minister we've decided to annex
new rule and your majesty before we
really have to box in the boss of a
possible state horribly depressing
yes say me I would like a mango a mango
yes I would like to taste a mango happen
it's impossible Your Majesty if they
only grow in India well I'm Empress of
India shall have one send
[Music]
you must be the Hindus very nice to meet
you you must be the Hadees you must be
dude
[Music]
more more MORE
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish she'd bloody Valvo today
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Ronnie go nice high opening me up me
me me open a panty Aquaman deep ironic
oh now hi yes yes shukriya Abdul to
veteran moon she home
Thank You Abdul you are an excellent
teacher
Bucci mother you're spying on me were
you letting her do yes I was as a matter
of fact you think that's entirely
appropriate I'm Empress of India what
could be more appropriate but in front
of the entire household you're
absolutely right I have no privacy here
hey Henry I would like to go with Abdul
to glass or she'll just not feel alone
but I believe just got here I'm a little
better now I could never tell
but still I'm gold buttercup poor little
buttercup
sweet little buttercup
a scene in ancient Persia
I am the Sultana of Persia the king of
all kings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
based on the New York Times bestseller
wonder tells the inspiring and
heartwarming story of August Pullman a
boy with facial differences who enters
fifth grade attending an elementary
school for the first time please welcome
Academy Award nominee special makeup
designer for the film Wonder areand iden
this is Aaron's first nomination
although he does has been nominated for
a BAFTA hello there
hi how are you I think you brought
guests with you yes I sure did I have
our director Stephen Chbosky here yay
[Applause]
right you look good thank you makeup did
you whip over there and do his makeup
this morning right so wonder it's been a
potential film project for some time one
of the biggest obstacles is my
understanding from the film being
greenlit was may was because of Auggie
Pullman's look and recreating the
Treacher Collins syndrome so I know you
wanted a real boy Stephen - in makeup
for your film could you both share with
us how this journey to the makeup we now
know came about should I go first well I
was approached and I was well I was
still working for Rick Baker in 2014
before Stephen was involved and I might
have been approached for it but it was a
different director back then and they
were basically thinking well you know
I'm not sure if we're gonna do this we
don't have the budget for a full CG a
visual effects so we're not sure yet and
it went away in 2015 that came back I
couldn't do it and then a year later
they came back again and that's when
Steven was on board and I met Steven and
I in that time always felt okay I made
this make could be done on this on his
boy but of course it's a very difficult
task to figure out how put him on a
shooting and stuff but I had a gut
feeling it could be done we just needed
to find it in it I met Steven yeah
that's funny cuz I thought it was a lot
more than a gut feeling it's not the
joke now I'm gonna say I just you
inspire a lot more confidence than that
in the room so congratulations to that -
in the world of the thank you till you
make it Bravo orient because literally
you're the reason why I did the movie
because I thought I loved the story so
much it was such a beautiful story and
the only the only obstacle for me was
could it look real and could it be done
practically because I knew that
CGT would just feel like a computer real
makeup would feel like a real childhood
and feel like a real boy and it was the
whole and we saw some early tests that
you know I was a you know a couple
directors in the film had fallen apart
many times and I finally I got very
lucky and it came to me and and I still
didn't know if it could be done and then
we had that meeting in Todd Lee Reubens
office and you know and after I met him
I thought okay this man is a genius
he understands this thing in a way that
I when you had already started pitching
your ideas about the I I don't want to
you know bury the lead as or but and
that was it it was I knew it had to be a
real child and I knew that the only
person that I had met who could pull
that off was this man so there we are
that leads to would you share with us
how you approach creating this makeup
and what did the makeup consist of
because many people don't realize that
it's a combination of prosthetics and
mechanisms right the makeup was designed
on Jacob Tremblay who plays Augie
Pullman and he was nine years old and
when we started production and I met him
how there you see the sculpture on the
life cast and and next to his regular
cast so basically has a neck prosthetic
from his chest going all the way bypass
his shoulders up to his chin cheeks and
then he has a front face and the nose
basically is completely covered and he
has a mechanical like carbon fiber
skullcap underneath the wig and
prosthetics that would have a wire a
thread system to pull the eyes down well
that was always wanted to ask you how
did the carbon fiber under the skull
mechanism work it was um it took some
time to figure out because he was also
growing during production but and then
there's that and but it took some time
to figure it out because I knew it
couldn't blue his eyes down the reason
why his eyes appeared rupees because the
condition he has is tweeted Collins
syndrome and I knew I couldn't going
down for nine hours he'd be very
uncomfortable so I said well it has to
be it has to be a way to release it and
and and
lock it and it was basically fishing
wired it was attached you know I bagged
that ran through a tubing into a locking
system that was hidden into wig yeah and
I have to say practically remember some
of the early tests that we did the
camera test you could you could click it
there they're up to three settings and
so sometimes you know to get the
asymmetry you had the great idea of like
well I could do two clicks with one eye
and one click with the other eye and
it's going to give you an asymmetrical
face without you know with with the real
mechanism which I thought was brilliant
that is brilliant
I think that the next still that we have
actually sort of shows you morning there
we go yeah you can see that's Michael
Nikki for ik who was here by the way
he's from Vancouver and he helped me
applied his makeup
[Applause]
I want to point out like it's
interesting just because you know when
you pull somebody's eyes down it looks
like that so he also wears contact
lenses actually to enlarge the iris and
that kind of filled up the bottom of the
eye you remember how much difference
that made without the lens and with the
lens yes sometimes it was amazing how we
would we would approach it and by we I
mean him we'd approach it a wrong way
yes
Royall we where it's you know one of the
parts of the condition this certain
thing with the eyes where there's less
there's less of the white and so we
thought and he thought can you get the
bigger you know the bigger iris and and
it's amazing how sometimes adding too
much of one thing led to the illusion of
too little of another thing and so it
was a really great practical way to do
everything I thought it was just
fantastic so now I've got a question for
both of you
so obviously Jacob was a minor and he
was 9 at the time now in such a big
makeup everyday how did your approach
change to make it work there must have
been many challenges and and is there a
story that you'd care to share with this
today you go first well the answer is
benadryl no it wasn't you know I really
don't have a story for it I will say
this because to me the the amazing
artistry that went on in the makeup
trailer was a mystery to me all I know
is Jacob Tremblay would go into the
makeup trailer as Jacob Tremblay he come
out as Oggy and not only in terms of
obviously his physical transformation
but there's something about the process
and I'm sure you'll have many stories
about what went on in the trailer itself
I only went in there a couple of times
but but it was remarkable to watch him
completely change because of the makeup
Jacob is over he's a rambunctious kid
he's a really he's a little bit of a
Hellion sometimes in a great way because
there's such a good kid but he's such a
cut-up and then but Auggie's not and
there's something about sitting in that
chair I almost feel like you know Jacob
is a he's a kind of a
once-in-a-generation talent and I think
he used the patience that he had to have
in that chair
almost like the patients that Auggie
would have had to have had through all
the surgeries there's something about
being still that that led him to this
character and then he'd go back at the
end of the day he'd go back in and get
the makeup off and he'd come out of the
trail and he'd take up again there's a
remarkable thing to see yeah I mean
amazing I mean for us of course it was
so much you know we hadn't had nothing
to lean on so it's when I first met him
I kind of need to get his energy a
little bit see what he was like I mean
was he able to do I mean he has teeth in
he has the helmet the wigs the lenses
DeForest I mean it's a lot for any actor
let alone him being nine and but you're
right I mean as soon as the protects
went on he would kind of hunch and it
would become Auggie and he'll become you
know a different kid and but you know at
the same time what it would a trooper I
mean we got it done in an hour and
fifteen minutes everything and so you
could shoot yet not on the first day
first day however you had to bring it up
but how great is a day coming you know
how are you telling time back there with
the sundial yeah that's right but I mean
I have to give kudos to to Jacob as well
I mean I don't think any other kid to
put it on through that in that age and
he would every morning he would come in
and the first thing you'd say Jacob in
makeup you know and it was just it was
just yeah you know he was great how
amazing my his parents supportive for
his did his parents stay with him in the
trailer yeah his parents were amazing
very down to earth I mean and they were
a huge help and I you know and I knew
going look test makeups at my shop and
and and doing all this stuff but I
warned him like it's fun now one time
two times but by day 20 and you still
you're halfway he's gonna he's gonna
have a bit of a moment and he did and
and I said please be there if he does
and he they were and they were amazing
yeah and and how many tests may comes
you know how many chances did you have a
go at testing uh I think we did two
different makeup tests and then we
really needed a third one but we didn't
yeah one in LA and one in Vancouver all
right now we had two at my
- in years okay yeah we kind of
refurbished some stuff in Vancouver but
yeah it was about two months two and
half months that's it yeah but you know
it's a bummer they didn't get your thurb
at the same time like you know one less
test means one less set of notes you
know I mean four that's right not you
know the one thing that was because I
thought my job as a director was more
kind of keeping everybody at bay because
I knew that you you had a vision for it
and and you were gonna pull it off and
make it great and whatever things can
people could say about could he be a
little more this old one more that
because you know people love this book
and everyone has an idea about what
Augie looks like and a reader his
perception of a character is very very
powerful so it wasn't a bunch of Studios
like mucking it up it wasn't that it was
more of just very passionate readers who
wanted kind of their thought in there so
it was his job with my help to just take
the best ideas leave the bad ones behind
and just move forward would you would
you say oh yeah I would say so I mean
it's just trying to find that right
balance between and also what all would
that much prosthetics and stuff going on
a Jacob still being able to act through
it and tell the story and that was very
important so you just have to eventually
find that balance well I think is a
wonderful film I mean it really is and
wonderful
[Applause]
so we're going to watch 10 minute drill
that was at the bake-off now and thank
you so much thieving for this one I know
one never just be an ordinary kid
ordinary kids don't make other kids run
away from playgrounds ordinary kids
don't get stared out wherever they go
[Music]
but it's okay if you want to stare too
my name is Auggie Pullman next week I
start fifth grade and since I've never
been to real school before I'm pretty
much totally and completely petrified
[Music]
[Music]
take that off please
whose re it's okay it'll be okay how do
I have to be so ugly you are not ugly
Auggie you just happy that we did you're
my mom oh because I'm your mom it
doesn't count
yeah because I'm your mom it counts the
most because I know you the most you are
not ugly in anyone who cares to know you
will see that they won't even talk to me
Madeline look there we I try to pretend
that it doesn't but it does you're
always gonna matter I don't know
let me listen
look at me we all have marks on our face
I have this wrinkle here from your first
surgery and I have these wrinkles here
from your last surgery the system
happened that shows us where we're going
and this is the map it shows us where
you've been it's your body right here
that's compliments of your dad I think
[Music]
come on get ready it's almost time for
the Halloween parade you're supposed to
not go away
mom says you won't say what happened
someone say something something well
tell me what happened it's not my
business
you took my day with mom so it is my
business I heard a job will talk to you
about me behind my back he said he
killed feeling like me jack well isn't
he the nice one there are no nice one I
wish I'd never gone to school in the
first place
but you were liking school I know you
were okay
Auggie I'm sorry but you're not the only
one who has bad days bad days do people
avoid touching you when a person that
silly touches you do they call it the
plague no it was all I had just don't
compare your baggies at school in mind
okay okay
Hey
did you notice that marina doesn't come
around anymore what you didn't shocker
yeah she went away to camp this summer
and now she doesn't like me anymore
why because school sucks and people
change so if you want to be a normal kid
Auggie then those are the rules I
thought you were at the library yeah
change of plans
hi I'm Justin misspelled Daisy threw up
again
bakit low [ __ ] looks um Justin this
is my little brother Auggie hey dude hey
what's on your case machine no it's a
fiddle
I should tell people it's a machine gun
that's a way cooler you know what
that's great idea you're right we're on
our way to the grocery mom's making
what's a club Fitzwater it's prime
making things water it's dad's favorite
you're welcome to stay if you want
Justin oh thank you very much it was
nice meeting you nice to meet you too
that's why by Auggie nothing to see here
so aren't we going to see the play um I
hadn't realized what the play was and I
don't think it will be of any interest
to a kid your age yeah you'd be totally
bored are you and Dad going Danny
although and I'm gonna stay here with
you what so now you're gonna punish me
by not going well you didn't want me to
go in the first place remember well now
that you know about it of course I want
you to come what are you talking about
nothing nothing you're lying it's just
something to do with via school honey
you just don't want your fancy high
school friends to know your brother's a
freak on Auggie okay that's not true
stop whining me I'm not an idiot I know
what's going on
did you see really bite mom well she was
whimpering and then mom tried to pick
her up and easy bit her do you think if
I can fix her she was a lot of pain
Auggie she's really old Auggie I want
you to come to my Play okay really
really
or he got years a couple of losers
thinking up the woods
oh crap look at his face he's a freak
Jesus nursing anything that ugly in my
life
maybe it's an orc Daniels go go where
hey talking to you Gollum just the one
master rule them all
what's your problem
boyfriends my problem hey leave him
alone
what are you gonna do about it get out
of my way no I said get out of my way
I said No
[Music]
what you guys know we may even know we
saw him fall you have a lodge I think
they were 7th graders they were huge
thanks guys you totally saved our butts
yeah thanks guys you know it's cool how
you stood your ground level dude
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Applause]
well we're now going to open to
questions from the floor
please welcome all our oscar nominees
back to the stage but as we begin this
section they're going to be helpers can
you identify yourselves in the aisles
please for everyone just wave around
there and they have microphones so if
you want to ask a question just put your
hands in the air and hopefully they'll
spot you but please you know refrain
from asking multiple questions because
there's an awful lot of people then I'm
sure that you're all bursting to ask
questions so one each please and then if
there's time you can ask a second one
and please keep it to the films we've
seen today and the artists up here you
know careers thank you come on up gang
[Applause]
no fighting
right so are you again yeah so before we
actually ask a question of the audience
I'm going to be very cheeky and ask a
question of the nominees that I would
actually like to know and I hope many of
you will join in with wanting to know
that too so we can keep it brief because
obviously it's not my time it's their
time but how did you begin on the path
of being a makeup artist and/or hair
stylist I started as a hair stylist knew
I didn't want to work in a salon for the
rest of my life
then I trained as a graphic artist which
was a technical technical drawing
basically and I designed interiors of
luxury yachts
my mother was an interior designer and
she had a client who was a makeup artist
and sadly my motivation was a picture of
her on a an exotic location leasing a
that beautiful breakfast and I thought I
could do that
a job ID because it was created for
drawing and hairdressing and that was
and then when I trained at school when I
was at school I was never taught about
how to get into the film industry it
wasn't a career choice so it was really
just from a photograph I'm ashamed to
say that that was my motivation that's
great yeah and me I started in a
hairdressing salon I did my
apprenticeship but again like Daniel I
knew that wasn't the path I wanted and I
just had to see an advert for a job in a
wig company with creations and I applied
and got it and from there I went and
worked other with companies and works at
the BBC and I did that sort of for about
25 years or whatever it was did some
teaching used to teach at London College
of Fashion and then I sort of fell into
it really because somebody said you
fancy coming out and I never went back
really that was it and I just loved it
so I went on from job to job I met
Daniel once again yes so that's how it
was really and here I'm still doing it
20 years later I was nine round knew
what I wanted to do makeup and yeah I
remember making wounds on my sisters
with bread dough yeah and true true
story I finished high school when I was
16 I went to makeup school in Amsterdam
five days a week and pretty much within
a year I started working the local TV
shows and little movies and when I was
19 I got in contact actually was 18 when
I got in contact with Dick Smith and
studied with him correspondence and I
eventually came out to LA when I was 19
worked for Stan Winston who sponsored me
and for my immigration papers and I
later Rick Baker and now on yourself yes
well when I was in high school I hated
school and I was figuring out what to do
after going out from school and I found
a one magazine
called Fangoria and i found a one
article about dick smith and so i
decided okay this is the one i have to
do and i started to make up on myself
the first one was Abraham Lincoln and I
did like a maybe for Lincoln on myself
but so after maybe six months I wrote I
found his p.o box address on the back of
the magazine and I wrote to him at dick
Smith and he wrote me but almost like I
received a reply in ten days and since
that you know at that time and he wrote
me back and he said okay
there's no good school out there so
whenever I come up with a new makeup he
you can send me a picture so he he can
give me a comment and we started the
correspondence and he actually gave me a
first opportunity to start work right
after I graduated high school and I
started professionally since eighteen
and on 1996 when I was 26 I was
sponsored by Rick Baker to move out here
and that was a start oh my carrier yeah
all right well funnily enough daniel
said he was going to work for or did
work for a luxury boat company because
that's what I was going to do I was
going to you know build the inside of
these luxury boats was a big company
back in the UK and just before that job
started we were driving past a college
and they were advertising this makeup
course and I said to my dad that's you
know that's what I'd always wanted to do
I'd always been messing around with
latex at home and bread dough and all
that kind of stuff so we just went into
the college into their open evening and
I said I left you know I left there have
been signed up and went to college and
sort of started from there really that
was back in 95 96 I guess I went to
college but my background mainly I I
went to college for a couple years and
then I moved to London in 98 and my
background is Madame Tussaud so I worked
at Manatee source for quite a few years
making the wax figures so that's where I
get my love for a makeup like darkest
hour because it's just recreating skin
textures you know skin color ends and
that kind of stuff so just that real
high detail work is so what I did so and
then a few years after that I left and
started working in the film industry and
sitting here now which is insane in
front of all these people say yeah
that's that's me I actually started in
the art department I did a week's work
experience on a TV shaper I really
enjoyed at the time and then they asked
me to stay on which I did through
University I did a fine art degree and
then I realized I it wasn't really the
right department for me about I did lose
the different jobs runner set dresser
buyer and then I thought well this isn't
really my department but I knew that I
wanted to I loved painting so I thought
maybe I'd be better at painting faces so
I try to get bits of work experience
within the makeup department and then I
did that for like a year while I was at
university and then I came over here and
trained for three months in LA and then
went back and then just did back little
jobs at the weekend after side work or
we go do better jobs at the weekend get
some pictures and then that would get me
better jobs and then I eventually ended
up here so yeah that's great thank you
[Applause]
by questions in the audience
put your hand up and see someone in the
or and see several people in the middle
Oh a question over here
lots of takers hi this is to the darker
cell a team and wonder you said gary
oldman if you asked him to do something
he did it
besides that is there anything actors
can do to prepare themselves for long
sittings can they do anything to prepare
themselves for long sittings yeah I
think if they listen to everything gary
oldman said in his interviews and
listened to it they will they'll be
better actors in the makeup chair and if
they listen to any of the interviews
that ourselves have done already because
they it's um we were at an award
ceremony the other night and the guy
giving Gary Oldman his award Malcolm he
said basically you know an actor it's
who can stick sit still the longest it's
like a competition and obviously Gary
wins that competition because he's seen
in the making a chair for that matter I
and completely still so I think if all
actors just sit there and do what we say
when we say it I think everybody will
create better work really I guess when
they don't know the answer the question
but um yeah yeah I mean with Jacob it's
very different because he's a kid so I
mean he just wouldn't sit any longer
than an hour and a half either he would
get very fidgety and stuff so but we
found it he watched a movie for
typically during hour and a half so he
would watch them he'd sit really still
he was actually really great would have
you know we mess around with them like
have a pillow fight or something
afterwards but to kind of keep him you
know but it's it's it's a you know he
has to prepare for it in his head but he
did great yeah excellent
gents another person in the middle
there's several up the back someone
mentioned laying in a facial hair I
wonder if you could explain a little bit
that process please
yes where normally one would have I used
to have all of my hair pre knotted on to
hair lace I think it's called Gore's
over here fine goes but the problem is
that doesn't last very long as most of
my colleagues will know on it probably
lasts a couple of days if you've got to
be a facial hair on a knotted gauze so
the laying on is basics the old is the
Italians use this method an awful lot
it's the hackling of hair it's the
mixing of different hair color and then
it's basically reapplied with pros a
adhesive you just blow down to the skin
and then you just start combing it out
and coming out and thinning the beards
out and then we then dress it with
Marcel tongs which are these tiny small
tongs they go in a heater and it seems
to last a lot longer if because the
proces is flexible it means that the
face can move and then you're not
forever bugging your actor sticking on
wig lace basically her lease as I
explained to you yeah thank you
and also it's a less it can seem quite
time-consuming but actually once you get
into the speed of it you can actually
become quite proficient and do it quite
quickly I was I was really fascinated by
the makeup and wonder it seemed
incredibly durable for what you were
explaining I was wondering what do you
use to keep those extensions that kept
his eyes drooped in place if if they
ever just popped off when he viciously
hugged his mom yeah actually that it was
quite some I'm glad you asked about that
because it's art Sakamoto actually who
was here as well he helped me build the
helmet the material because of tension
of it obviously it would pop off and I
actually had build the helmet for myself
first before I ever met Jacob just to
see if the technique would work and
originally I did it was that we had
vinyl cast
I backs with the fishing wire stitched
into a piece of fabric that was cast
into the line back of mind it's like
this big and it worked on me but it
didn't work on Jacob because we just
constantly pop loose so we found that
backing it with a little silicone I've
got the name now and then we couldn't
use any releases because it would
somehow residue would stick with it as
well so we use PVA and then laid a
fabric in there at the stitched wire and
then cast the vinyl on top of it let it
set up and then I would feed the wire to
the tubing and stitch it so it was just
every night I had to redo that every
night and it's like a midnight stitching
anything but it made to make a better so
I chose to do it well hello
Becker this is for the team for darkest
hour what research did you take into
coming up with a final look for Gary as
Winston Churchill well research well
when I took a life cast of Gary and a
bunch of pictures and also we did body
scan 3d scan and what I did was just
gathering up the photograph as much as
possible and it bought a lot of books
and DVDs and from DVDs I did DVD
captures and also watched his biography
to understand who he was and tried to
kind of when I create character I always
try to and try to understand who they
wore is just not just what they look
like so I can put the essence of charger
on in the makeup so just just adults
with researches and trying out the hard
part was just I cannot just put the face
future on Gary and make it look right
because it's it will look like him
wearing a mask so try to figure out the
good balance
and still Gary - moves through the
makeup so he won't be something really
heavy I think there's some down the
front stop hi
I was I have a question for Arjun
representing wonder I understand you
also worked with del Toro on Pan's
Labyrinth and I wanted to know how
closely were you in conceptualizing
those monsters and how did that prepare
you for your work on wonder let me think
about that one it's so completely
different obviously while I did that for
DDT and as a shop in Barcelona I was 24
at the time and I constructed the pale
man basically but I've is such a
different character because obviously
he's based on a real condition I'm not
sure how how connected that is other
than me doing a lot of research with
hospitals and talking to families who
had kids with three - colon syndrome
making sure that that that's right so
I'm not sure how to answer that question
fully I hope I'm not disappointing you
hi I just would have an additional
question about wonder in terms of
medical or legal considerations do you
have anything that you have to consider
in terms of the makeup for a child or is
it all just the logistical things that
you've already explained I think other
than him being extremely tight on the
clock my Steven will remember
I saw you stressed out quite a few times
and no but that's that's I mean other
than that yeah just trying to get him a
make up in time and so Steve could shoot
as much as he could I believe we had
nine hours from door to door in
Vancouver
there was an hour extra than they have
in the United States for example if I'm
not going if I'm not wrong so that extra
hour for production was very essential
and and I remember meeting some of the
kids coming through with their families
on set but yeah it's not some not so
much as a question as a statement first
of all I'd like to offer my
congratulations to all the nominees your
work is absolutely incredible but my
statement is directed at one nominee in
particular Louise Shepard I've known her
for 20 years
her work is incredible as she is and I'm
very happy to finally see her receive
the recognition that she so richly
deserves
[Applause]
did you pay for that was lovely
yes well certainly I've known Luke for
so many years we actually frightened
each other in the in the reception
before had any other questions in
darkest hour did the smoke affect the
makeup I got all the cigar smoke Gary
was smoking I don't I can't member the
facts of how many cigars he went through
but he went through a lot and obviously
the continuity the cigar so you know
you'd start a cigar and then you'd have
to start another one up cuz the other
one's got the first one's gone too sure
see then cracking another one I think
they're 50 pound each weren't they and
he got through thousands I mean he like
loads I mean is all the time
very green him to say that he thought he
should get an award for the cigar
continuity yeah hi my name is Michael so
when you guys first heard about the
movie you were gonna do like not even
the test or anything you just heard what
movie guys were working on what was the
biggest concern / where you had going
into it and that's for all the panel
correct yeah that's for all of everyone
I think it's always the time factor for
us really I think probably for most of
us you have very limited time to to you
have to scale them what one would like
to do for a makeup you know we'd all
love to do these great big makeups but
it's it's really about time a hair and
makeup we probably get an hour hour and
15 tops and you've kind of got a
complete everything and it's all it cost
thousands and thousands of dollars or
pounds so I think for me it's the time
issue really that's what it my main
consideration is
I agree yeah and also people always
imagine Oh people always imagine that
you have a long time with her with the
main artist but in fact they need to get
them out of the chair even quicker don't
they so you don't have a lot of time at
all for me it was well again believing
that this should be done as a makeup and
I I didn't wanted to fall back into
other departments so I I felt this could
be done but it just you know I was away
of a lot of research but my case it just
always I go into the mode that tried to
imagine how it would turn out to be in
my head and go through the hair from
almost a few days and try to figure out
what to do because sometimes you know
like a makeup job like a lightness
makeup is so hard almost impossible so I
go into the imagination record days to
figure out in my head and give them
answer if I didn't do it or not mine
mine was because other than a few day
but I worked to Gary on a film just
before darkest hour called hit man's
bodyguard and then it was a few weeks
after that he sent me a text message
saying hi it's Gary how do you fancy
doing Churchill and which you know I've
never had a message like that before and
I guess so my I think my biggest worry
was the fact that Gary had recommended
me to CAHSEE and he had recommended me
to Jerry the director and the producers
and stuff so and they were like who's
this guy from the UK like you know why
do you want him to do it and he said
that's the guy I want so then I just
felt immense pressure because he's stuck
his neck out for me you know he if I was
going to let anybody down it would be
letting Gary down ultimately and then he
would you know let Joe down and the
producers say I think that was my
biggest my biggest worry was not to let
Gary down
I'm saying yeah my biggest worry was
probably whether we were gonna do a good
enough job for Kazu and because nobody
really knew who we were and Cassie's so
brilliant and whether we were gonna do a
good enough job of the makeup and then
when I got given the job of the wig
whether I would do a good enough job for
Diana and hopefully all right I think
someone said to me when I was
considering the job because I didn't
accept straight away I had to think
about it and spoke to Gary and they said
you know it's a CAHSEE maker you don't
want to be the guy to mess up a candy
maker so this could be this well this
could make you or break you this job and
I thought oh thanks that's mark my boss
at the time but you said but good luck
you know what have you decide I'm like
chairs say yeah that's a view them using
Joe
hi I'm Dave firstly congratulations to
each one of you for being nominated most
of your British I think so here's my
question to David and also in the team
for who worked on wonder the skin is
sometimes really sensitive when you put
prosthetics on so in your case how
difficult was it to keep that on for how
long did you have to keep it did you
have to change it every single day and
how did it work on the little kid as
well so is this for darkest hour or
wonder football and you go first
oh thanks so what do we do yeah we we
prep Gary's skin by cleaning it with
kills a product which takes anyway any
oils and things from the skin and then
we use derma shield as a barrier and
then we used a glue called Telesis 8 it
changed just before we started on them
on the job and Gary it sort of used ppi
products before he's use their glues and
paints and stuff so he's quite adamant
that they wanted to use the same glue
because because his days were so long he
was in makeup for well it took us sort
of three and a half hours to put it on
then he's in makeup for ten or twelve
hours a day and then we take it off and
because you know there's not much time
for when we take the makeup off to then
sticking it back on again
the routine of that every day we were a
bit concerned about but you know we just
worked out that using that particular
glue with the removers and just doing it
slowly you know Gary's skin was
absolutely fine we didn't have any
problems with you know redness or he
never got his skin wasn't irritated any
point was it really it was yeah I mean I
think if we'd had a problem with that I
don't know what they would have done
because Gary's in every single almost
every single shot so I think I mean they
were concerned about it the producers
did come to me and say what happens if
Gary's skin breaks out and we have a
problem
and I said I just I can't answer that
until it happens but fortunately every
single day it was fine you know I mean
ask quite a lot of someone's skin you
know because all the coverage silicon's
not breathable so everything's happening
under that all day but we were just
fortunate that the products were used in
gary's skin and the way we took it off
so I'm always quite adamant that if I
can to take the makeup off myself if I
apply it because especially if you're
applying it the following day if you
just hand it over to somebody else and
they're kind of ripping it off their
face and that jabbing them with brushes
or using the wrong products or the wrong
mix of products you then get in the next
day and you apply the glue onto Gary's
face and he would it be really sore and
it was sting and then you know yeah it's
just not ideal so but yeah we were
fortunately it kind of worked out long
answer that with Jacob just used this
young his scheme was actually quite
holding up really well because it's you
know I remember using Telesis five for
most of his facial pieces we actually
didn't glue the neck it was design and
such awaited it was very snug so we
shaved down the core someone a neck went
on the snugness of it itself would stay
on so there was no glue on any of this
part and that also helped buckling
because how quickly silicone necks
buckle and look fake so that eliminated
that problem again it was also designed
just to cut makeup time and then I
believe we used tell us is aid
underneath the eyes Jacob got a little
sensitive to the smells of all that and
he'd like to tell us his aid to him it
smelled like oranges and he have all he
also believed his purse eggs were made
out of cartilage and so you know ya do
have cartilage on my face I'm like yes
yeah so and he would go around I said I
have cartilage on my face and like me
yes you do no but and then in the end of
the day we would clean it with I believe
isopropyl myristate and some steaming
towels and he has to know various
products it looks like I mean the time
has just flown I don't know
about you but it just seems to have
whisked by unfortunately we don't have
time for any more questions but excuse
me I just like to thank everyone for
coming today and making this a memorable
event great thanks to our special guests
and of course all of you the audience
for attending today well before everyone
dashes off hang on I've got to remind
you you have to wash watch the Oscars on
telly tomorrow please
it's the 90th it'll be great then you
can see everyone here and cheer them on
and there can only be one winner but
these are all our winners so far so
please join us in the lobby
[Applause]